[Música]
la derechista keiko fujimori el
izquierdista pedro castillo se
enfrentaron anoche en el último debate
presidencial en perú antes de la segunda
vuelta de las elecciones del próximo
domingo ninguno de los dos candidatos
terminó como vencedor según los
analistas en medio de unas encuestas que
arrojan un empate técnico
seis países de américa latina están en
riesgo de colapso hospitalario ante el
recrudecimiento de la pandemia con un
millón de fallecidos en la región
acumula un tercio de los muertos de todo
el mundo en las últimas horas del
domingo la confederación sudamericana de
fútbol suspendió a argentina como la
sede de la copa américa prevista para
comenzar en menos de dos semanas en
medio de crecientes contagios y muertes
por covite 19
el partido comunista chino anunció este
lunes que permitirán a las parejas
casadas tener tres hijos un nuevo cambio
en la normativa de natalidad en el país
en donde se ha venido registrando un
envejecimiento de la población después
de décadas de aplicación de la política
del hijo único que terminó en 2015
tenemos un reporte desde beijing
bienvenidos a una nueva emisión
informativa en france 24 gracias por
estar con nosotros mi nombre es one
pupiales si el vencedor claro terminó
anoche el último debate de presidencial
en perú previo a la segunda vuelta de
las elecciones que se realizarán el
próximo domingo la derechista keiko
fujimori y el izquierdista pedro
castillo se midieron en un cara a cara
que tuvo a la salud y el manejo de la
pandemia como uno de los temas
principales según los analistas en
ninguno de los dos candidatos logró
aprovechar este encuentro en medio de
unas encuestas que señalan un 'empate
técnico'
vengo de este espacio del magisterio
nacional preocupado por la educación
vengo con las manos limpias
vengo a decirles que soy un hombre de
trabajo un hombre de fe un hombre de
esperanza me formado trabajando todo el
tiempo de mi vida yo sé lo que es rascar
una olla para compartir y darle alimento
a mis hijos para dar alimento a mis
alumnos
yo sé barrer una escuela donde no hay un
personal de servicio yo sé cómo es que
tenemos que cautelar como tenemos que
cuidar lo que se suda no más pobres en
un país rico palabra de maestro
usted señor pedro castillo con su
lenguaje y sus mensajes de odio de
división de lucha de clase no solamente
ha generado las agresiones contra
periodistas sino el día de ayer contra
ciudadanos que libremente salieron a
expresar su opinión yo hoy vengo a dar
propuestas propuestas para sacar
adelante nuestro país en medio de esta
terrible crisis sanitaria y económica
sueño con un perú donde preservamos la
paz y no se promueve la violencia
hay más incertidumbre sobre la
celebración de la copa américa prevista
para comenzar en menos de dos semanas la
confederación sudamericana de fútbol
conmebol suspendió en las últimas horas
del domingo argentina como la sede del
torneo misma decisión que se había
adoptado hace unos días con colombia el
certamen se encuentra así sin anfitrión
y este lunes la conmebol se reúne de
urgencia para buscar otro país que pueda
albergar la copa en argentina se
registró un récord de contagios el
pasado jueves mientras que el número
total de fallecidos supera los 77 mil si
el reflejo de américa latina una región
que vive un repunte de la pandemia y
acumula un tercio de los fallecidos de
todo el mundo para romero nos los
explican en el siguiente informe
la pandemia no tiene 100 en américa
latina' al contrario vuelve a empeorar
con gran velocidad la región ya acumula
más de un millón de muertes
aproximadamente el tercio de las
víctimas mortales en todo el mundo y
tiene una de las tasas de mortalidad más
alta mientras que el promedio mundial es
de 46 muertes por cada 100.000
habitantes en américa latina' los
fallecimientos suben a 162 además según
un reciente informe de la cruz roja seis
países de la región están en riesgo de
colapso sanitario especialmente
uruguaya-argentina donde tanto las
muertes como los contagios se encuentran
en sus picos más altos
en extensión a pesar de las persistentes
altas tasas de contagio mucha gente y
lugares ya no mantienen las medidas de
salud pública que sabemos que funcionan
contra el kobe 19
quizás todavía no sabemos el impacto
completo de esta pandemia
impact of the standard
solo entre el 17 y el 23 de mayo los
países latinoamericanos registraron más
de 12 millones de nuevos casos de kobe
19 y 31 mil muertes una cifra que lleva
estable desde hace algunas semanas en
niveles alarmantes además la vacunación
avanza con lentitud en la mayoría de
países toda sudamérica lleva 114 3
millones de dosis de fármacos inoculadas
aproximadamente la mitad de las
administradas por solo eeuu sin embargo
las buenas noticias son que este viernes
concluyó la última fase de los ensayos
clínicos de la vacuna cubana soberana y
que brasil reinicio la fabricación local
del fármaco de astrazéneca
lo avanzábamos en titulares el partido
comunista chino anunció una
flexibilización en su política de
natalidad las parejas casadas
podrán tener ahora tres hijos esto en
medio de una preocupación por el impacto
económico que pueda tener décadas de
aplicación de la política del hijo único
que terminó en 2015 desde beijing
nuestro corresponsal adrián foncillas
nos envió el siguiente informe
la medida ha sido aprobada después de
una reunión del politburó a la que ha
asistido el presidente chino xi jinping
la reforma legal se daba por descontada
debido a los graves problemas de
envejecimiento que sufre china pero los
expertos dudan de su eficacia que
recordad que en 2015 la derogación de la
política del hijo único no sirvió para
estimular la natalidad hoy en día no es
la ley la que brinda los nacimientos
sino un contexto socioeconómico muy
parecido al de occidente de las parejas
jóvenes rechazan las familias numerosas
argumentando las extenuantes jornadas
laborales la incertidumbre o la carestía
de vida además añade un factor chino
como ese de la extrema competitividad de
su sociedad lo que aconseja a muchas
parejas jóvenes concentrar todos sus
recursos económicos en un hijo en lugar
de dividirlos el último censo chino
corroboraba que la población está
creciendo a su nivel más bajo durante
décadas lo que anticipa
graves inminentes como la reducción de
la masa laboral o la sostenibilidad del
sistema de pensiones vamos a medio
oriente porque el líder del partido de
extrema derecha naftalí bennett dio un
apoyo crucial el domingo a un gobierno
de unidad en israel para destituir al
primer ministro benjamin netanyahu
la decisión de ventas podría permitir al
jefe de la oposición y el lápiz formar
una coalición de partidos de derecha
centro e izquierda y propinar a
netanyahu la que sería su primera
derrota electoral desde 1949 más en el
siguiente informe
y a ir lápiz líder del partido centrista
y es a ti que terminó segundo detrás del
a la derecha del likud de benjamín
netanyahu en las elecciones de marzo en
israel tiene como fecha límite el
miércoles para anunciar un nuevo
gobierno las posibilidades de éxito han
dependido en gran medida del
nacionalista naftalí bennett un ex
ministro de defensa cuyos escaños en el
partido y amina en el creset han sido
suficientes para darle el estatus
decisorio ahora dice que está dispuesto
a intentar ayudar a formar un gobierno
de unidad
uno tiene que tomar responsabilidad en
tiempos tan críticos
por eso pretendo hacer todo lo posible
para crear un gobierno de unidad con mi
amigo ya es lápiz
juntos sacaremos al país de la caída en
picada en la que está atrapado y
devolveremos a israel su rumbo de
necesidad y se le mostró lo bajo un
posible acuerdo de poder compartido
bennett se convertiría en el primer
ministro durante dos años reemplazando a
benjamín netanyahu netanyahu lo acusó de
fraude del siglo
citando promesas públicas pasadas en las
que dijo que no se uniría a lápiz y
llamó a los miembros del partido de
benet a apoyar al likud
hago un llamado a nuestros amigos que
fueron elegidos por votantes de derecha
hago un llamado a los que tienen
conciencia y un buen camino por delante
sigan por ese camino no creen un
gobierno de izquierdas el gobierno es un
peligro para la seguridad de israel y
para el futuro de israel visto que no
todo en ti no quedan muchas
negociaciones para que el lápiz forme un
nuevo gobierno el bloque de partidos
anti netanyahu tiene poco en común
excepto su deseo de poner fin a los 12
años de netanyahu en el poder y evitar
otra elección que sería la quinta en
poco más de dos años
[Música]
terminamos con ciclismo porque el
colombiano invernal se proclamó campeón
este domingo del giro de italia el
corredor de línea grandes como las dos
grandes vueltas y con 24 años
bernal superó sin inconvenientes la
contrarreloj de milán última etapa de la
corsa rosa y se llevó la carrera con una
ventaja de 1 minuto y 29 segundos sobre
el italiano también o caruso segundo
clasificado en chía a las afueras de
bogotá hubo celebración de la familia y
seguidores de gang quien se espera viaje
a colombia en los próximos días
la información continua para 24 quédense
porque más mucho más
24 cuatro.com
[Música]